we are asked to find the equation that
represents this line and the easiest
type of equation to find out based on
just being given a line as an equation
in the in slope intercept form which is
y is equal to MX plus B where m is the
slope where m is the slope and B is the
y-intercept the Y value of the
coordinate where our graph intersects
the y axis so the y intercept is very
easy to find we can actually figure it
out
just by inspecting our graph we
intersect the y axis that's the y-axis
right there it wasn't labeled right
there at the point X is equal to 0 X is
always going to be equal to 0 at the y
axis so X is equal to 0 Y is equal to 3
so our y-intercept is 3 and it makes
complete sense if X is equal to 0 Y is
equal to 3 so B is equal to 3 now the
next thing we need to do is figure out
the slope of this line figure out what M
is going to be equal to and remember
slope slope which is the same thing as
our M or what M is represents that is
our change in Y for a given change in X
so let's go from this point to some
other point that where we can definitely
figure out its coordinates so that looks
like a nice integer coordinate right
there and let's figure out what our
change in Y and our change in X was to
get there so 2 our change in X we're
starting here at X is equal to 0 we're
moving in the positive x direction by 5
so our change in X our change in X is
equal to 5 1 2 3 4 5 we went from X is
equal to 0 to X is equal to 5 so our
change in X is equal to 5 that's our
change in X now what's our change in Y
well we had to go down 2 we have to go
down 2 so our change in Y when our
change in X is positive 5 our change in
Y is negative 2 our change in Y is
negative 2 we're going down we're
decreasing in Y so our change in Y is
negative 2 so our slope is negative 2
so we figured out the slope we figured
out the y-intercept we can now write the
equation that represents this line it is
y is equal to this character negative
2/5 times X that's M right there plus B
B is 3 plus 3 and we are done